[Music]
Jesus even the DreamWorks logo shows the
cruel kidnapping of the poor moon Fisher
this movie is unexpectedly terrifying
today is best day ever
alien narration I am oh i has been given
this name by my many many friends later
Oh we'll admit that he doesn't know why
they say oh when he shows up by the car
people universally saying oh when he
shows up why isn't his name oh please
this goes on for some time we are safe
from our enemy that go captain smek not
only shows an example of their sworn
enemy to the boov crowd he blows it way
the hell up and animates it for full
terror value this planet is full of
great stuff
look at these delicious fruits why did
you assume the footballs were fruits I
mean you obviously robbed a Walmart to
bring this many back with you so why
didn't you also take baseballs and
soccer balls and I guess you found one
of those Walmart's that doesn't pay
attention to tiny aliens wheeling out a
whole cart of footballs without pain
also the captain starts this
demonstration now right when they're
within distance of the planet meaning
the boov did not know where they were
going or why until now that makes me
feel so good it takes all three fifteen
minutes for this kids movie to go right
for the potty humor Jesus even
Despicable Me had more restraint and
that thing had a fucking firk gun
what fun at a party boov do not party so
the boov are the anti trolls which I'm
guessing is how that movie ended up
getting me dreamworks said hey you know
that movie home we did in 2015 let's do
the exact same movie only with creatures
who love to party
complimentary BJ's for everyone the moon
turned off the Earth's gravity all at
once but some things start floating
faster than others this guy gets a hole
cut into his bathroom while he's
showering but apparently he's safe as
long as he's in the shower
because he doesn't get evacuated
immediately like everyone else does also
this evacuation would definitely miss a
heaping portion of the world and it
looks inefficient as I know the balloons
are expert colonizers and everything but
they're not city planners for humans
right how did they get all these fucking
houses and know where to plant the trees
and even though the city looks huge they
captured everyone in the world sure you
can technically fit the entire human
population in a place the size of New
York City and all but that's standing
right next to each other these people
have individual houses also if they
gathered up all the people in the world
what happens to like the Eskimos or
we live in the jungle they're supposed
to immediately adapt to using a
microwave and having a two-car garage
and that also means all of your warlords
Psychopaths and dickheads are randomly
living next door to decent families this
planet may be a bit of a fixing it up er
yeah but it's got the same breathable
atmosphere as you have back at your last
place which is super goddamn convenient
also the boov landed on this planet five
seconds ago yet hundreds have decided to
walk into laundromats and nail salons to
amp up the hilarity this shot suggests
that there are just as many bicycles in
this city as there are toilets and that
grand pianos are anywhere near both of
those items it also suggests that
DreamWorks is incapable making a movie
without toilet humor also these toilets
from a huge city are all being removed
at the same time but are all perfectly
empty and clean these guys told what
sector 179 is they just found out what
planet they were going to about two
minutes ago they explained to everyone
where they needed to go all around the
world feel like this movie could have
been better if it didn't try to condense
the evacuation and repopulation of the
earth in six minutes
welcome home neighbours boov do not have
neighbors these assholes reproduce they
don't party they don't have neighbors
they always run away from things I'm
gonna guess it's some kind of spawn
reproduction but that's entirely a guess
whoever lived out here put a cook book
with a bunch of science books one of
these things is not like the other one
of these things just doesn't belong only
both on a brushing his teeth by the
toilet here since they were all floating
into space the last time we looked this
one cats here there should be a ton of
others especially in the big city and if
they took the pets too wide this asshole
get left behind is this Kirk Cameron's
cat sorry
mom's not here Casper do you mean the
evacuation technology wasn't 100%
foolproof
we've just got here I mean they're still
moving in and everything so how did tip
have enough time to not only set up her
hideaway here but create all this anti
boo propaganda tip set up this Rube
Goldberg contraption in case someone
came by instead of an alarm or something
that could actually combat one of these
assholes
well this explains how cartoon riri can
reach the gas and brake pedals it does
not explain how she can see over the
dashboard also as we're about to see the
streets are filled with boob walking
around but somehow tip will be able to
avoid all that business and not be seen
driving around ever hello Jesus Christ
we get it nobody like so if he were this
toxic why didn't they just leave him at
the last place because I'm not allowed
to move you're always saying the funny
things
why is oh the only one that consistently
talks like this
I know we supposed to be weird and
offensive to the boov but there's no
reason why he always talks how we think
an alien should talk and the others just
occasionally do it
parties are useless and take a valuable
booth time what these assholes do that
require any time whatsoever what are
these things okay I shall send an evite
to you so you can join later god damn it
it's like the screenwriters wanted to
combine a fish outta water story with an
alien story using dialogues I think
Millennials actually use invite has been
sent to entire galaxy will receive how
you mean the boov and the cord use the
same emailing system or whatever the
this is just a lazy way to stir up
conflict and how many boov accidentally
hit that send all button out of the
billions of the Oh can't be the only
dumbass alien in their population right
and you don't even have to be a dumbass
to make this mistake you are a fugitive
boov initiating self-destruct
nope just take him to jail instead of
simply blowing up his ride the abduction
of the entire human race took a couple
minutes and the boov rounded everyone up
with no problem they can't locate one of
their own kind that's right next to them
guess the little suction thing missed
the spike when it considered all bikes
useless despite being on the open you
know for a girl that's trying to escape
the alien hordes and find her mother tip
sure is taking her sweet ass time at
this market life-form detected not human
mother this is how these things operate
there'd be at least a million more
people like tip that we're accidentally
holding their pet and movie doesn't even
alien right I want ideas movie
completely wastes of vocal performance
from Steve Martin that's at least trying
to go forward he doesn't do many movies
these days people so we need to make
them count you are all invited to a
party just head to the Milky Way turn
right at the Big Dipper third planet
from the Sun if O's invite was intended
for all the boov who are on earth then
when I had a did he include these
directions at first the problem was
explained to us that because a sent the
invitation the core would be able to
track them down just because of the
signal or whatever so why did everyone
freak out at first if they didn't know
what the invitation actually said if a
sends an invite that makes any sense
then it doesn't matter if the gorg got
it or not
also Oh didn't have the idea to send the
evite out until he talked to Kyle at the
crosswalk which means he did a
tremendous amount of recording and
editing for this invitation within
roughly six seconds I am putting you in
charge which has anyone been in charge I
mean those just hanging out in a market
that's nearby to where the chase began
in the first place who B can't decide if
these boobs or genius trackers or
Oh repairs tips car and some kind of
weird booby and pick my ride fashion and
it takes up a lot of the movies runtime
tip seemed surprised and all the weird
renovations but what was she doing while
he was taking all the stuff out of the
convenience store this seems like
something that might have been funnier
if we actually got to see him do it and
explain it to her while I was doing it
but hilarious car guy yo what did I say
interrupt his home movie to bring you an
episode of Tom and Jerry I guess there's
no way that this easily seen car will be
detected in their flight from New York
to Paris okay seriously moving what's
the timeline here because it's still the
same night the children and Rihanna
escaped twice then the grand pooh-bah
did his world broadcast then the boogly
started looking for them in the same
place after Oh had fixed the car so when
did I have time to install a goddamn hot
dog machine in the car you just have
pets for fun and companionship
Rihanna's performance here makes her
role in battleship look better and
better each minute this is a funny gag
but why was the seat already set on the
very back setting especially since
they've been lined up perfectly until
now huh this move gets security cam
footage from the store that somehow
tracked the pimped-out cars that sped
miles away from the cameras reach you
guys had summer in the Statue of Liberty
statue of smack neglecting that this
happened in one day why the is the
statue of smack out in the middle of
nowhere I too has to break pee or as you
calls it the number one when did I ever
find out that humans called pee a number
one unless tip somehow mentioned it
somewhere during the trip I find it very
hard to believe that she did what a
convenient way to get the movie into
bath um humor again
the bathroom humor isn't stale at all
but let me ask you this how does eating
a urinal cake register as a bad taste to
him we saw this mother for brushing his
teeth using toilet water earlier should
I send the continued gross out bathroom
humor or the fact that there are still
toilets around after we were told they
were useless and floating into the sky
earlier also these people apparently eat
inanimate objects for food yet they
totally know what lemonade is pick a
lane movie Oh Kyle not only isn't
traveling with any other boobs for
backup
he doesn't radio in at all as soon as he
sees the car turn 3 I Do's not I pump I
was been living with the other booze all
his life and would absolutely know about
the whole turn green once you liable
I'll just open with this Kyle survives
this I guess the boob didn't care enough
about that giant explosion at the gas
station to actually send a unit from
their search patrol you have tricked me
into listening to a debilitating sonic
weapon Oh thinks this is bad wait till
she gets to bitch better have my money
do not dancing I was supposed to be the
unique asshole in the sea of boov
commonality the party so he definitely
knows the dancing is this has actually
helped gym person responded when he
asked how much longer this stupid-ass
scene lasted not to belabor the you know
what I am belaboring the point
this motherfucker does everything
different from all the other boov key
witness dance scene which was only made
to sell soundtracks anyway I see Steven
Spielberg was on hand to animate the
shot moments ago you are kicking on me
and yelling which is seeming more to be
mad than sad Oh whose Ray's change
colors all the time do their emotions
somehow did not realize there are
multiple emotions you can have at once
please come on I need ideas this story
is so bare that the screenwriters margin
notes made it into the actual script we
has a rule nine mistakes and you are out
how many mistakes do you have sixty to
sixty doing mistakes if the boov are
supposed to be the stoic on feeling
alien race why would they have allowed
Oh to stick around for so long everyone
clearly hates him and he contributes
nothing to their society they somehow
flew this car into goddamn Paris boov
headquarters without anyone noticing I
thought the big brain boovs would have
stopped my invitation by now if I could
think of the idea of stopping his
invitation which is
what the big brain boobs figured out why
didn't oh stop the invitation itself why
did the entire race of boov panic when
they found out the invitation was sent
out when it's apparently easy to stop
the invitation I shall input my password
oh and his super long password in like
four seconds but after a caps lock joke
gone wrong it later takes him like
totally forever in a race against the
clock to enter it complete with all the
bull to race against the clock usually
implies in a movie but I would not but
you might but I would not buy side
effects of watching this movie may
include brain leakage homicidal thoughts
pancreatic discomfort temporary rage
blindness impotence forgetting where
your keys are facepalm injury incessant
SMD aging and a deep desire to chug
bleach but do it all slow like so I can
finish jerking off the funny thing gets
that close to someone's eye cliche also
a movie makes the tip of the Eiffel
Tower and look like a super sharp spear
instead of the actual radio tower that's
on top of it because all we really care
about is watching aliens Steve Martin
sort out his B material I can't wait to
tell mom I actually went to Paris yeah I
shall have a lot of fun telling that
story to the rest of the enslaved human
race
none of the super annoyed and extremely
mobile boov think to follow the one
human and car that just kept their home
base it is possible I will continue
making hilarious mistakes
I've watched 52 minutes of this movie if
it makes you feel any better I don't
think you've made one hilarious mistake
yet I know when the other boobs said oh
they were not happy to see me
expositional roadtrip bonding cliche
this whole me and someone was living in
this mountain top made of completely
rock just let that sink in gorg the gorg
are apparently into dubstep which is an
easy indicator of their evilness yeah
it's the Shusher that was described
earlier in the movie but my question is
if the gorg can locate the Shusher
because of some sort of signal of the
myths why can't they just always follow
wherever it goes
instead the gorg week just long enough
so that this can be blamed on it this
works I will now sing the boov deaths on
probability of success oh how I wish the
paying movie-going public said the same
thing to this rookie movie
it is gorg superchip how does oh no this
and why is he so good at fixing parently
emerging technologies from different
alien breeds ah see a mechanic back in
boo Ville movie leah has time for a
makeup montage apparently ain't got time
to explain that that's a lot of people
it still not nearly the amount of people
this movie thinks it is also apparently
they've been peacefully enslaved for at
least several days here without any hint
of an uprising against this unarmed and
incompetent boob population in the midst
of 7.3 billion people tip eagle-eyes the
exact location of her mother she's got
some fancy zoom and enhance contact
lenses the one mother ship will be here
soon
I know Oh doesn't know and what the gorg
are really after but if the gorg get to
earth and find that their sworn enemies
have gone why would they could about the
planet the only thing that keeps them
going is the stone fueled boov hunt and
rage boner I know they're busy escaping
the gorg here but nobody at least
recognizes the fugitive boov whose
picture was plastered all over the world
for the last several days
this magic super chip can simply be
inserted into anything man it makes that
thing better despite being incompatible
with probably anything except gorg
hardware but there are like a million
ways to design a spaceship so why does
everything have to look like a discount
Death Star okay so the boov are on the
run and it's great oh stuff that thing
in the hoo-ha and make it work but the
gorg have a lot more of those things
right it should be able to I don't run
them in no time flat and finish off this
boov aside we need a new captain I
thinks it should be OH
Kyle way overestimates owes
qualifications based on the slightest
bit of evidence
mere minutes after everyone hated him
for all the stupid mistakes he's ever
made he also takes charge of this
situation and guesses everyone else
feels the same way based on the same
evidence you are not the only boov who
makes mistake my mistake is not being
your friend oh please Oh captain Oh was
this directed by Francis Ford Coppola
wait
remember Jesus this movie has more
unnecessary songs in it than the
live-action Beauty and the Beast remake
sure nobody seen the hot mom who's been
looking for her daughter this whole time
tip travels from New York to Paris then
to Australia where she knows the entire
world's population is located and
searches for 3 minutes for her mother
then promptly gives up just like these
boobs are doing more celebrating the new
Campton than they are continuing to
evade the closely trailing mass of
heavily-armed sworn enemies
neither can i considering the gorg was
literally right on their tail but
somehow the boov ship gave them a Juke
move on the way back to earth then land
it then Oh was able to find tip inside
this mass of humanity none of whom beat
him to death for being one of their
alien oppressors all the people talking
to tips mom peel away and dramatic I
finally found my mom fashion what does
breaking the key in a lock do don't they
have buttons inside the car that
automatically unlock the door and even
if somehow breaking the key off in this
particular lock made it impossible to
unlock the driver's side the passenger
side is still okay to go right also what
does ou expect to happen if he dies in
this scenario he just stranded his
friend and her mom in a car in midair
and expected them to figure out how to
get down and somehow it will create a
giant force awakens' rift in the ground
trap oh and won't be able to stop its
momentum so that this movie can have
five extra minutes of bolt you were
scared I almost made a number three not
too hard it is still a possibility and
we're back in our lane now movie thanks
for your correction even though the gorg
have been shown not to be the bad guys
he still has spikes and skulls on his
body so he ain't completely innocent
what was in that thing it is entire next
generation all of them remember this
rock was just sitting in the gorgs
office on a pedestal that's where the
gorg keep their entire generation just
sitting out in the open easily knocked
over I was always told not to put all
your children in one basket also holy
for most of this movie Captain smek has
enslaved two species somebody get him
try it immediately for Warcraft what's a
he's a DJ apparently that gorg is last
gorg seems like it could have sent a
message out to the boov that his only
remaining children are in that rock but
their captain carried around and we
wouldn't have needed this movie to help
him get it back what do I know - King
weeks later and everything is back to
normal
Grice this movie should just go ahead
and admit it exists in a timeless King
wormhole I guess it's supposed to be
funny that this big brain boob is still
playing dead after all this time but I
don't find funny is that someone had to
carry this move around so that it could
play dead everywhere it went
what is happening to my vine and instead
of any satisfying characterological
discoveries for the final part of the
movie we get another dance sequence with
a Rihanna song he has a new start in a
new home and now everyday is best day
ever until I ran into all the racists in
the world who don't cotton to our new
alien species ever since cinemasins
began the most requested thing has been
TV since and now it's a reality click
the link in the description below to
check it out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
Who am I
[Applause]
[Music]
boov do not party this is what makes
time travel possible
what's capacitor this is uh this is
heavy duty dr. Benson we happy here we
happy